yo what is up it is the time that you
have been waiting for whoa big offseason
is almost coming to a close the NFL most
of it at least is reporting for training
camp today and I kind of feel like the
off seasons almost over yeah
how you guys feeling first week whoa big
second week whoa big pre ad goes on for
life football I know you're protecting
you like a Kramden sausage into that
shirt today
okay left goes got a football yeah and
you just have yours I went and got the
football over there and brought it let
me see you grip the football you're
gonna throw it let me say this is how I
would hold it like that
two and under for one in under three
okay so one and under how would you hold
103 one see how you would hold that
that's don't even horrible are you a
finger up guys so so you're talking
about my my first thing I look at is in
the first one and then the third and
then I feel like I wonder three not on
three you're under three of you I'm a
two in five guy so this is Sims on the
laces those are the first things I'd
ever look at it at your fourth finger is
in the second slot and your pinky finger
is in the Fissel right it's it's a
fascinating thing because a lot of guys
do different ways and you know Dan
Marino is more of a two and five guy
John Elway was like a one-in-four guy
makes the ball real small towards the
top of his hand right like that
iron Rodgers is two and under six show
us what Rodgers looks like this is Aaron
Rodgers and Brett Favre was this as well
but two and under six which I told
widest boys he is Aaron Rodgers and
Brett Favre of the reason the cliff
hanger on your right nostril dude if you
pick me apart won't go yep there we go
that's why I said no you're not touching
the football sorry how do you I got
messed up because I remember seeing a
Kurt Warner video yeah and Kurt used to
put his pointer finger on the tip of the
ball and I said it gives you that push
right and I watched that and then the
rest of my life I was like Kurt Warner
so yeah messed me up oh yeah there's
only two guys that I really know that
ever really did that with finger on top
now Kurt Warner I wouldn't say he's the
most
it's like spiral thrower ever it's not
gonna be easy to throw a spiral when you
put your finger up like that Terry
Bradshaw did that too he put his put his
finger towards the finger he was the
national champion javelin thrower - yeah
so he just made it up how he threw the
football like every year I've had
conversations where like he was a lot
like my dad they'd go into training camp
and just go this feels good this year
let me just throw it like this I'll do
it and you see that on film usually no
it's too hard I usually take like still
pictures you know when you see a still
picture or something then I go oh okay
that's how he grips it right like
Brady's a two and five two and four kind
of guy kind of sounds like you're
partial to the two and five thrown right
no I'm not I'm not at all it really
doesn't matter it's all about feel it
really is it has no difference
that's the weirdest one you've seen man
there's a I'll tell you Lamar Jackson's
was pretty weird this year where he's
got like he bikes his middle tooth he's
like this almost where his second third
and fourth finger are really tight
really tight together and it's on like
lace one and he only has that on the
lace and I've never seen someone hold
their ring finger and their middle
finger that close together it's throwing
a football and I would think at some
point if his ins accuracy doesn't
improve on some of the throws we've
heard about through training camp but
what I've heard they're gonna start to
go wait how do you give a ball of all
the ways to change a throwing motion
whether it's feet whether it's your arm
motion whether it's your fingers on the
ball what's the hardest one to change
for someone that they've done their
whole life yeah most people don't know
how to get their upper body aligned in
the right way to throw the football to
actually give themself a chance to throw
it to their utmost capabilities like
usually when we get NFL quarterbacks and
the Simms household or college
quarterbacks that we you get them and
you go yeah but you're almost in your
own way here you're the one blocking
yourself from being able to get that
extra 5 miles per hour and we show them
a few things like that shoulder turn
creating opposites like you would like
hitting a hitting a golf ball at the
driving range right you keep the bottom
part of your body pretty still and then
you rotate to create those opposites and
that allows you same thing with football
same thing with hitting a baseball same
thing with a forehand antennaes torque
it's exactly right torque is really the
name of the game on all sudden done yeah
it's funny it's you you think of a golf
swing is so complicated
keep your head down put your feet the
certain way whatever throw footballs the
same way it's a very center feel like
you could start getting in your own head
and like thinking about your fingers and
you forget about everything you're right
you're right there's times now it's
since I've retired and got out of
football where I go man you know
sometimes I just was way too old for
analytical and my like own McCaffrey
time I've thrown a football with you
yeah the first through few balls you
throw your so deliberate that it's it's
almost like are you gonna do this the
whole [ __ ] catch yeah yeah first
three you're like just throw the ball I
just want to get a feel for it coming up
a little bit later we will be having the
wou big offseason awards very excited
big Phil is going to be joining us
probably in about 20 minutes and we're
gonna break down the ridiculous
quarterback tears on ESPN all of you
have been DMing me Sims has opinions
both of them do and we're gonna get
Phil's top 5 running backs because
apparently he's got stuff to stay and at
the end of the show today we're gonna
have an interview with the president all
the Hall of Fame 6:9 over 400 pound
David Baker and he look I said I'm a
little disappointing this whole tío
thing and he kind of came back so me a
manned up he did so we'll have that
later ass if he's not too disrespectful
he's such a nice guy I would never even
think about fighting right he's three of
us I feel like we'd have a chance yeah
he's like a real-life one one I don't
know if we couldn't really mess with
that guy big nuisance Monday Todd Gurley
has been paid Adam Schefter was the
first one to break it for your extension
for Todd Gurley so it never got to the
point where Le'Veon Bell was 60 million
total 45 million guaranteed most
guaranteed money ever given to a running
back Adrian Peterson would be second and
then say Kwan's third so it shows you
running backs really have not gotten
guaranteed money over the deal what was
your first reaction to this glee
happiness I'm glad to see the running
backs getting paid I hope this corrects
the market a little bit I mean everyone
kept saying this sets the market do you
agree with I do I do
yes it does finally give a marquee name
that got a respectable deal for
everybody to go okay this is the bench
mark and I don't think anybody would
argue that Todd girlies I mean at least
in the top five
I say he's the best running back in
football right now but he's in that top
three top five conversation and yes this
will set the bar going forward but you
think he's the best running back in the
NFL I did and everyone after this went
man Le'Veon bells gotta be upset and
your take was Girly's better than levia
early is better than levy on bow in it
and again yeah the more rushing yards
receiving yards rushing touchdowns
receiving touchdowns at better yards per
catch and a better yards per reception
to the levy on last year exact and he's
300 argue he doesn't have as good a
quarterback a good offensive line or
maybe not even the good as weapons on
the outside if you really want to see
better OC but it's not like Todd Haley's
chopped liver but I think the big thing
there is he's three years younger
exactly that's really where it all goes
to the things I look at and again I love
me on bells awesome I like I got a man
crush on the guy I'm just trying to keep
it real for everybody yeah three years
younger and I think the thing that
separates Gurley from Le'Veon Bell in my
mind like we said a little last week is
his explosive ability there's no stat
line for going hmm
that guy can go 80 yards to the house
we've never seen levy on bail go to 82
the house it's not in his game he is a
like big chunk runs or Gurley or Zeke
are the guys that can really take it to
the David Johnson they go to the house
cuz when they open up they can run like
track speed type of guys where let me on
bail doesn't have that but yeah you said
it
I mean Gurley a 0.7 yards per rush more
on the Year last year over five yards
per reception and yeah like he's in the
prime of his career and he's been a
physical freak really ever since we've
known him whether it's not you give a
fewer GM Chris Sims like we talked about
pay these guys their money but would you
pay our running back forty five million
guaranteed I would especially in his
like time frame right there like the
Dallas Cowboys they should be looking at
this going okay this is kind of our what
we should do
during maybe next year and just get
ahead of the Zeke Elliott thing right
away running backs are going to take
these type of deals because they're
gonna go table girl he's gonna go damn I
didn't get hit once in college in my ACL
blew out so you're telling me I can get
forty five million right now before the
season starts and we can do it and I can
be
pretty much good I wish think it's a
value I I do I think the way the NFL
going I think we're gonna see the
running back become more get more
respect paid wise because I think some
of these freak writing back so we're
seeing in the league right now the
Ezekiel Elliot's the David John says
Leonard for now it's all these guys this
is the one thing I think people are
missing out we're gonna see a longer
shelf-life from these players I think
going forward because of the running
back by committee nobody gets drew like
driven into the ground like the early
2000s or the night and we're not we are
growing at 500 carries he carries a game
or at the very least it was 24 people
were fresh yesterday because Ron Rivera
said Christian McCaffrey might get 200
calories right and they were like that's
a big workload that's a big workload but
like ok do you know who led the league
in rushing attempts last year Le'Veon
Bell 321 rushes hmm so yeah 200 rushes
is in the Isiah Crowell well Johnathan
Stewart range of Carolina Panthers and I
would expect him to get 200 there's this
impact the Levien's future I don't think
levy ons coming back to Pittsburgh no
matter what people need to realize he
cannot negotiate his contract the
franchise tag deadline has passed it's
over but I don't think there's a chance
he goes back to Pittsburgh next year and
I know I heard Jeff Schwartz talk about
there's no teams with money Cleveland's
gonna have money and the Jets are gonna
have money and I could see both of those
teams going after Le'Veon III due to I
could see a lot of teams going after him
I do that thing you see Todd Haley going
after levy unbalanced right I mean
everybody's in a love of Todd I mean a
levy on bail on their offense just
because he he is so versatile in the
pass game run game
he doesn't really fumble the football he
can run with power when you want so he's
gonna fit in just about any offense the
big thing is I think would let me on
bail in this conversation is I do think
it takes away his leverage it does I
keep you won't love you bail can't ask
for 17 and a half million anymore
there's a guy here that's younger and
more explosive who has better stats than
you and he just settled for a hair under
15 million a year and I think that's
really gonna hurt let me on Bell's
prowess are asking abilities with the
pits were still a lot of people saw this
deal and said levian was right they
should get paid a lot this will help
levy on your saying because girliest in
your ma
better and younger this actually hurts
Le'Veon from getting that 17 and he
might have to live in that 14 fit right
exactly I get to make the argument
though that he's a wide receiver as well
well Gurley has led his team in
receiving more than then let me on bells
leading receiver for the RAM right
that's where I just before can you know
what I mean right let me on had 90
something yes you're right Le'Veon was
in the past game is asked to do a little
bit and maybe I'll say more overall
conceptually wise right he's and Bobby
runs a different variety and we're
trying to get to you this way you're the
first person I've heard say that this
hurts levy on I do because everything
I've heard he's asking for 17 to 18
million dollars a year cuz he's our
running back receiver get combined and
I'm saying here's another guy out here
that does everything you do and is in
the offense that knows how to utilize
him to and he did it better than you and
I don't think you can ask for more money
than him because he's three years
younger
he hasn't been banged up as much as you
and because of that I think yes it does
hurt girlies I mean love you know bells
total asking price I'd interesting yeah
I think the other question that it made
me what he accept my question is if they
offered him forty five million
guaranteed because we have never heard
that we for ten right exactly we've only
heard ten guaranteed we've heard thirty
over the first two years the comments
that I saw cuz what's what's turning now
is the NFL is finally allowing is
finally embracing social media things
like the check down and the NFL post and
NFL players are starting to comment and
NFL players are speaking truth chris
johnson got underneath and said it's
finally time to pay the running back and
all that and i show him the police
report post no bleacher report had one
with like levy on bail acting like cardi
B you're not going to understand the
meme at all but being like my team says
like you should pay me now like for levy
on Bella's really fine no car to be
Odell and levy on commented but the real
thing was is a lot of the comments were
get those guarantees like a B was I get
those guarantees again I think that Kirk
cousin started this yeah and I think
Gurley getting forty five million I
think it always comes down to the
guarantees I think we've told the fans
for years right the kanto tools only the
guarantees matters his contract is a
four-year forty forty five million
dollar contract basically that's what
this right
like 11 yeah and you get that too and
you go okay and if you're a running back
and you put yourself in their shoes and
you go damn this this position I'm
playing right here I got people hitting
me from every angle I can't see all of
them all of it it's dangerous I think a
lot of them will maybe buckle like girly
could have got more than this next year
I was gonna say what the NBA contracts
on the MBH contracts were coming out and
Chris Paul got something like 160
million years old with problems like
that's where the NBA is that's crazy
[ __ ] Kevin Love got four years 120
million dollars he's not one of the
thirty best players in the NBA and yet
we're asking we're pissed off about
Odell Beckham jr. who's arguably the
best player in our league eight he's
getting eight and how dare he asked for
more that's where again I know we say it
all the time I do that girly commented
under an NBA post these guys are getting
a hundred and sixty million I'm just
trying to get eighty yeah the truth is
he took 45 so Gurley is showing you even
in his mind I'm just trying to get
eighty I'll take half of what I want
just because I can't believe you're
giving me guaranteed money the other guy
that it made me ask a lot of questions
the Rams have now gone out and they've
paid Brandon cooks they've now prepaid
dr. Lee Todd Gurley Erin Donald is
officially holding out for the second
offseason right and everyone's telling
me how valuable is he's the Defensive
Player of the Year he's arguably the
best player on that team how are they
doing this with Aaron Donald still being
there not having a contract is this
hurting his money it kind of has to
right I mean you would think so but what
we really don't know is exactly how a
lot of these contracts are truly
orchestrated what years the money is
spread around exactly in yeah so where
they can always find creative ways the
salary cap is continue to go up we also
have to continue to learn as fans like
you mix either digest that the contracts
are gonna be bigger than what we're used
to I saw The Kooks contract he's getting
twenty seven point nine in his second
year in his first year he's barely
getting any yes yes so like they've
uploaded that second year but I just
think Aaron Donald now gonna hold out
again he's the one that I'm most afraid
of that's what I said on Monday show
note I think Odell gets his money I
think Khalil Mack gets his money
Aaron Donald's the one that I'm going I
think he's gonna be the most upset I
really do
he I do I mean he will be if he doesn't
and he has every right to be especially
wouldn't you give a guy like in Dominic
ensue as done nothing for the team he
gave him 14 and a half million dollars
guaranteed in the first year if Fenric
got a big contract and they announced it
and I got a big contract they announced
it and you weren't getting a new deal
yes and it was said my name is Sims and
Sims and left go right it's gonna upset
you this has to brother and Donald the
wrong way yeah I'm sure it does there's
no doubt about it seeing Cooke seeing
this it's got to rub them the wrong way
but also you know who knows what they've
told his agent or him at this point
anyway so he might be feeling okay we're
kind of close we're gonna get it I think
that deal will get done I really do yes
I do just because I think McVeigh and
Wade Phillips understand what kind of a
special player this guy is and they will
continue to put pressure on the front
office to make sure it gets done and
it's in and also what we're seeing is
Kroenke and everything they're going for
it they're trying to win Super Bowl over
LA and this will be a big part of it I'm
a firm believer after I've realized the
NFL windows are so small it kind of
makes sense to go all in in your tight
two to three year window before the
rookie quarterbacks get there a big deal
it just does yeah the one guy that's
also upset right now Julio Jones want to
talk about a guy that might really sit
all the cards are aligned they were so
proud of him because I didn't think he
would do this you didn't think so no you
thought it was gonna be quiet Julio that
always played by the rules
Johnny team guys camping training camp
risking forty thousand dollars in fines
per day which actually never happened
that's a thing everyone always makes it
seem like the players are gonna lose the
money if you wouldn't upset the players
even more make them actually pay those
fines never happens to those type of
guys the franchise type players that are
in this situation the team doesn't ever
cut you know hey here's a you know 50
million guaranteed by the way you've
missed thus 30 days of practice so can
you pay us back a million of that right
now
six hundred seventy good luck doing that
with an NFL football player see how I'd
like pissed off you'll make him Arthur
Blank did come out and say he's going to
be a falcon for life but
that's easy to say because he's kind of
not in those negotiations yeah but you
saw the Thomas to me trough Dan Quinn
extensions and went what the [ __ ] well
it just bothers me I mean yeah Thomas
Dimitra off and Dan Quinn get extended
what are your extensions right so they
get extended nobody ever says anything
about that no big deal I mean let me
just put it this way Dan Quinn I like
the guy a lot I have respect for him
at no point has he been in the
conversation from one of the three or
five best coaches in football zero at no
point ever ever ever ever and Julio
Jones has been that every year he's been
in the NFL Dan Quinn and Thomas dimitrov
had oh wait let me just check Oh two
years left on their deal how dare Julio
ask for a new deal with three years left
on this deal even though he's still one
of the three best receivers in football
so that's what drives me crazy again the
hypocrisy of this you know oh here's the
mint upper management he's a white
collar guy we're gonna let him get paid
and get a new contract but hey you blue
collar guy who's putting everything on
the line and limps into every game every
week because we abuse you and try to
throw you nine million balls every game
and you can barely practice and then you
come out on Sunday and still ball out
how no we can't pay you we can't do that
sorry that's just any way that Thomas
dimitrov negotiating his own extension
it's part of the reason he hasn't been
able to negotiate Julio Jones no I don't
think so because he's an agent too and
that agent will deal and in him will
deal with a Arthur Blank and when
they're sipping on red wine and how long
could this last man I hope he makes a
last until he gets paid I really do I
don't know what yeah they're camped or
Gronkowski thing where they're gonna go
you know okay well throw you an extra
signing bonus this year and we'll
revisit next year something like that in
the end of the day I think envision
that's what happened give him extra cash
you find something to give them a little
extra right now and then they revisit
when the season's over and I have games
at canvas canvas I think the first two
right and their offense was all their
defense was really bad yes they got
burned by that one Tyler Eifert play
that like twice remember it was like a
stop in the middle Yeah right exactly
like they attacked cams positions go
Philly Carolina New Orleans Cincinnati
to open the sea Philly Carolina New
Orleans since an apparatus you're facing
a team that you might be trying to face
against for home-field advantage and
then two NFC South opponents Carolina's
daddy with their corners and stuff I
mean Pittsburgh week five oh my gosh
that's a brutal schedule yeah and not
only that we also need to admit Steve
Starr Sarkisian if he doesn't have Julio
he's not the most elaborate play caller
in the world that offense could start
off really slow and they lost Benjamin
Wright so it could be Mohamed Sanu and
Calvin Ridley I think it's yeah I would
be concerned just because I you know I
would be shocked up but we didn't see
the flaws of Matt Murray and more if
Julio Jones is in there you know again
Matt Ryan but I know we're gonna get to
this list in a minute but he is not top
five quarterback material I think a lot
of people put him in that conversation
because of stats and things like that
and I just don't see it that way a
little bit of injuries are already
starting to trickle out again my my big
prediction is that by the end of this
week into next week unfortunately
there's going to be anywhere between six
and ten ACL injuries ACL epidemic it
happens every year but Sam Beale the
cornerback that they drafted the Giants
did out of Central Michigan or Western
Michigan I think it was in the can third
round the Supplemental Draft right
shoulder injury out for this season
Browns lose Ricardo Lewis who I think is
a very good young wide receiver yeah he
was the one that caught that miracle for
Auburn when he was in college he's out
for the year that's a big loss I mean so
much so that apparently the Browns are
eyeing Dez Bryant right
you also mentioned hey look they lose
Ricardo Luis Josh Gordon is mysteriously
stepping away I don't know how you can
just sit there and depend on Josh Gordon
and I'm saying there's an all
seriousness like I'm rooting for Josh
Gordon I want him to kick ass to do that
I'm just saying if I'm running the
Cleveland Browns
I'm not putting all my eggs in the oh I
can depend on Josh Gordon what a basket
with the injury to Ricardo Louis and the
question marks around Josh Gordon what
do you think about Dez Bryant as another
guy out there with Jarvis Landry and
Corey Coleman for the Browns
yeah
I do think it could work there certainly
in the Todd Haley offense they could
find a similar juju Smith Shuster role
which oddly enough juju remember I
actually compared him to a Dez Bryant
when he was coming out but yeah I do
think that could be a place where he
would fit in he's gonna fit within that
offense and I don't seem a team
perspective because that's always the
question that's gonna be the big
question what does I I don't think it
he's as bad as what people making I
obviously think would be great to have
his energy up then it could Landry and
Tyrod are already bringing that that
energy that we're gonna win Dez has one
you know they've B's been on a lot of
teams that have gone to the playoffs
he's had some big catches please son
that should have been catching yeah but
I actually think his energy would be
pretty good for the breath I I don't I
don't disagree I mean again other than
Jarvis Landry he's really the only guy
that you can go I can depend on him
right now who else on I know Corey
Coleman's got potential but again these
are all the reasons it's just too many
unknowns right now and Dez Bryant is
unknown we do know one thing about Dez
Bryant he's got great strengths yes he
can catch contestant footballs can any
ain't afraid to compete right and there
is something about that to add attitude
to a football team I I think he's
actually a good fit up there i I don't
disagree at all I think Todd Haley can
handle him I think a Tyrod Taylor where
the Dez Bryant will work to and he's and
you know Atta to your point which is the
spot on about he's used to winning the
cowboy culture that's what I would give
them credit for yes your microscope
there I mean you are the king of Dallas
and the king of Texas and every game is
like a playoff game for the Dallas
Cowboys they expect to win and they
expect to be in the playoffs and and be
a contender all right let's get big fell
on the phone well dive into these
quarterback tears and get into these
running backs but the quarterback tears
you already got Dan Patrick calling you
up this morning yeah you have become the
quarterback ranking guru whatever
rankings come out yeah well what does
Chris say what does Simpson get Chris
Simms on the phone sim seventy it is a
thing I'm excited to hear dad's voice
he's probably like what they're calling
them in early hey Perry
Adam son yes what are we doing just
collecting checks over here checks man
oh man no no that's what you're stealing
checks no okay then we called you is
okay that we called you a minute early
felt you know I I'm I gotta get over it
y'all must have done something I don't
know I'm I was getting ready to rip your
ass for calling me late of course you
know today Adam is Christopher's
anniversary right I did not know thank
you Dad yep anniversary and everything
I'm sure he's just going to just you
know him he's good
what would you do know him you know my
son would sit on a couch and starve
before he gets up and fixes a plate to
eat food you know that tell them dad um
I might he says I remind him of his dad
yeah my dad could be one inch from the
refrigerator sit at the table maybe
playing cards or whatever my mom would
be at the other end of the house he go
hey whoa you know whatever I'm not gonna
say what he used to call her and she'd
come March then he goes hey how about
getting me a beer out of the
refrigerator and I just used to look in
going damn you can just turn around open
the door got it my family makes fun of
me because when we're at even like any
holiday or even this past week we were
in Jackson Hole music Yellowstone when
we have like the picnic or anything my
wife makes my plate yeah that's part of
the deal I mean that's you know it's
gonna change no brother I hope it will
you know for you because I've always
kind of cooked and grilled yes and I
love it every night this is how it goes
at them I'll say to my wife what are we
having for dinner
well I haven't thought about it um what
do you think what you could you you want
to make something you want to go out
yeah it's amazing I mean for at least
the last would essentially turned 50 she
said I'm done yeah it's funny that you
guys brought up family cuz on Mondays
show a new character was born that the
fans are just loving
Barbara chickenhead ripping off bonds
telling some grandma Sims stories that
so Phil what's really cool is
Christopher and me both that we both
have a grandma named Barbara and they
both sound pretty similar so this is
your mom and I if you could just take us
into to some memories of her ripping
some heads off chickens I'd love to kind
of start our little okay here we go I'll
make it quick
of course we lived on a farm I have
there's five boys three girls we would
all be out in the yard before dinner
time or you know that time you get a
break whatever it's after school we was
playing baseball or something some type
of game and my mom would walk out the
yard in here tick tick tick grab the
chicken throat put it down put a
broomstick over its neck grab his feet
and pull the head off yes she do anyway
neither town did it make a sound no it
doesn't it happens really quick and if
it make us and she go all right when the
quake inside the chicken quits jumping
around what have you thrown with a hot
tub of water over there and pluck it and
bring it in and I'm like oh yeah it is
the grossest thing to pluck a chicken Oh
Mike so how many chickens do you think
you've plugged in your life well you
know look I was a really young boy so
what I had to do it it was man it was
rough I mean so I would probably help
one of my other brothers but not a lot
because if that was for the for my older
brother and sister to do but my
grandmother who you know what's her
inexperience she would walk out the yard
and go Ditka she grabbed one and I just
grabbed him by the head and shake it and
that's it oh wait she would you see that
off
she just shake it just jerk her real
quick the head came right off oh yeah
you didn't know these things about the
play look the great the greatest moment
my life is not only won the Super Bowl
its day we moved off that far so I'm
sure it's not about what Christopher is
going to do for his anniversary is about
what his wife's gonna do for him that's
what we got going yeah we'll find out
later we'll see yeah Chris has a tier
two husband and and Danielle's a tier 1
1
that's kidding it's not adhere to
husband come on brother nah work hard
he's not afraid to work so that I'm
making material
alright so ESPN released their tears in
which God did they really yeah they did
so you know let's make up another you
know before we get going this top 100
list of players who boats on that Phil
would you like to know why these
companies do these things yes I do I
know why oh do you have no imagination
they don't know what to talk about so
let's make up a list and argue about it
and stand up and scream it makes no
sense but it doesn't matter
exactly well ESPN they had voters ten
general managers five head coaches ten
coordinators ten senior personnel
executives 5 QB coaches and ten other
jobs
there were only four quarterbacks that
came in Tier one and they listed Tier
one as this a Tier one quarterback can
carry his team each week the team wins
because of him he expertly handles pure
passing situations and they named them
Aaron Rodgers Tom Brady Drew Brees and
Big Ben
what are your thoughts on that right
hard to argue with all of it I don't
know drew Brees yeah he can carry the
team just because it's so well designed
and what they do but physically he's not
going to just you know do it on the
physical in which the other ones can so
but I'm not gonna argue look he's gonna
go down with all the records when it
comes to throwing you want me to gripe
about a few that should be in that art
do you want me to read what they said
about Brees a secondary coach said look
at third down New Orleans has been
number one or close to it every year and
that's what used to throw people open
tight windows defense coming to get you
and OC said the guy is dominant he is a1
he can throw to win if then if they had
any defense for the last five years we
wouldn't even be questioning him he'd
have won another Super Bowl yeah yeah
I'm not gonna disagree with a lot of
that he how they did their defense did
come around for him last year as well as
it could should be better this year
and you know they're great on 3rd down
there they got great imagination
he really can find receivers and I've
said this many times about him because
every quarterback that comes out Russell
Wilson
you know Baker Mayfield he could be the
next drew brees dime just go no they're
not no they're not not going to be close
it's not the same type of player and
what did we say Christopher drew brees
is the tallest six-foot quarterback that
you'll see in the NFL broad shoulders
long arms big hands and really athletic
that's what you know I don't know what
what people watch but he's got
tremendous feet and you know he can move
around and make some odd throws too so
and then the imagination and Sean Payton
is awesome call a caller and has tons
and tons of things to do on third down
so his next quarterback
trust me is gonna put up unbelievable
numbers and Drew Brees retires Yeah
right that's where I would push back on
it and under the Drew Brees thing I mean
first of all I always go back to my the
2015 year drew Brees couldn't play
Carolina Panthers were the best team in
football
drew Brees doesn't play Josh McCown Luke
McCown plays not Josh McCown Luke McCown
play yeah he goes into Carolina and
throws for 335 yards hasn't played in
three years but runs that offense and
you go Dan the offense look just like it
doesn't drew Brees
so the game with Josh made more amazing
than one right last play ditch whatever
exactly so but I think at the time yeah
one time during the game McCown was 20
of 21 or 21 or 22 right and I just go oh
my god so that's where it bothers me
because to this the people who voted in
on this list we don't know who made
those comments but if there are
executives executives those was an OC
and a DB coach
okay okay so that's that's fine I'll
give it a little more credence like you
uh she was the tier two guys that were
below let me just finish with him the
first thing with Drew Brees - the other
thing too
the Saints have told us he's not a tier
one receipt quarterback the Saints told
us oh we were gonna draft Patrick
mahomes oh he's a tier 1 quart by then
we're gonna become a running football
team and have the best old line in
football oh yeah he's a tier 1
quarterback so they don't I believe Sean
Payton he doesn't think he's a tier 1 he
might have been for a long time but he's
39 he's really awesome he could still
win a Super Bowl but to say he's the
third best quarterback in the league I
don't care who voted on us they're wrong
who are the guys that you're upset that
are behind all right so I know your list
the sim 70 official I just look at this
is where I don't know where dad would
agree with this or not but like Drew
Brees at 3 Roethlisberger at four Matt
Ryan a 5 all phenomenal players I'm not
trying to discount anything they do but
just Breeze in Roethlisberger or up
there in age and I would displace those
3 with a Wilson Stafford and Carson
Wentz and they would be tier 1
quarterbacks for me in my book I mean
Carson Wentz Russell Wilson and Matthew
Stafford can carry their team with their
physical ability better than Drew Brees
Ben Roethlisberger can at this point of
their career that's that's what I would
argue with that I'd like to disagree oh
yeah I can't I mean you know people I I
had this argument with somebody last
night I was throwing with a really kid
I'll tell Christopher later and he can
tell you at him but ok very talented
college quarterback Division one and all
that we were talking about guys and I
said man Matthew Stafford and one of the
kids that was there said something I
said Matthew Stafford has saved more
coaches jobs and gave them giving them
extra years and whatever and made
Detroit somewhat relevant just because
he is truly athletically physically
whatever phenomenal not he's not good
he's phenomenal and you all D you know
oh the comeback wins I don't know how
they do that some of them are so bull
all they had to come back when they were
down 3 and they kicked a field goal or
something they win I don't know that
counselors to come back when if you do
it with 11 minutes and 50 seconds going
on the fourth quarter I think that's how
they do it yeah they do but Matthew
Stafford
does it untrue do-or-die last-minute
things in games the year before was
incredible and hey look played hurt at
the end of that year everything in the
playoffs in the playoff game and he's
right Carson Wentz would absolutely be a
tier 1 quarterback it depends how we're
doing this but since he got you got hurt
now it's hard to put him in that if you
wants to fill it up Eagles last year I
heard somebody on TV this morning though
well Carson Wentz has an OK arm I just
want to tell what you must not watch the
game of course I know they don't know
they don't want a football like we do if
you wouldn't see Carson Wentz inform the
old saying no what's wrong brick wall
you can throw it to the car wash now
getting it wet let's get them all out
there he can put steam on it and make
those four and five throws that decide
wins and losses in many many games right
and a Russell Wilson come on what are we
gonna say he says it all
with his actions almost every single
week that's right he's unbelievable yeah
this is where I'll just and again it
might sound like I'm being a semi hater
here but I'm just gonna follow me down
this road just this is I'm just laying
this out there for the public whoever
listens to the Sims and left called
podcast listen again Matthew Stafford
tell me who on his team that's been a
special player over the years other than
Calvin Johnson named me a really good
defensive player that's special okay
there you go
maybe on the minor and dominance no
Darius lay it's really just - it's
Calvin dodge and in Adamic ensue say
that Golden Tate Marvin makers and games
they don't go out and win people open
tapes not getting double-teamed exactly
they and and he's hasn't had a hundred
yard rusher on his team since a hundred
yard rusher game from a running back
since 2013
yes he's never had a thousand yard
rusher and then here's the this is gonna
sound like I'm a Tom Brady hater and I'm
not but I'm just gonna this is our facts
of the matter people act like Tom
Brady's up there doing it by himself and
I want to go
okay it's greatest coach of all time
greatest tight end in the history of the
sport Oh Randy Moss the second greatest
receiver in the history of the sport was
also their greatest offensive line coach
greatest slot receiver we've seen in
modern day Foot Locker we Richard
Seymour Vince Wilfork Ty Law its Hall of
Famers Daniels McDaniels you go through
it so that's where I just push back
against it where people just look at the
bottom line and there's no context with
it at times well you listen you know who
are we talking about we're talking about
people that just you know I watch all
the shows every day one for one reason I
like to get my blood pressure pressure
boiling before I walk out of the house
you know so I really get sleep fired up
and you know Oh ton breeze up there do
it by himself
yeah that's the big thing all because he
doesn't have Julio Jones but we forget
the running backs the system everything
that goes with it but listen I'm ranking
this in a different way of whatever I
still without question make him I would
put him number one in the in this
quarterback thing because I know Aaron
Rodgers is physically more gifted right
but Tom Brady these paths this past year
I had this I'm just this is crazy I just
have Scott Dunn watching one of the
games because I was trying to take some
shots to show him the kids how I want
them to throw the ball right and you
know this past year he got hit a lot he
did and he moved around and his feet he
might be the slowest guy in the NFL but
his feet are four foot they're 4.4 yeah
no I mean he really has tremendous foot
movement to throw the football and he's
he might be the best at it
all right I don't read I want to read
some quotes about the four guys that you
were just talking about Brady Wilson
Stafford and Wentz and I want a level of
one to ten how much it upsets you in
terms of what you're here attend the
month of stand the most upset one the
least upset I don't need a whole like
soliloquy just what dad just said there
to I mean it is amazing with Brady's
feet well Brady's been like we've we've
said a million times Brady's been better
the last two years to me than he was in
2010 11 and 12 yeah and that's what I
think something believable about it here
is a quote from a defensive coordinator
about tomber
Bill Belichick is an outstanding coach
if if Brady is not quarterbacking if an
Belichick is like the rest of us trying
to get our [ __ ] together Brady is a
special dude he understands going back
to college he has to compete for
everything all the time that's what
makes him great level of 1 to 10 I would
probably give 9 like that's just yeah
he's mad at Bill Belichick is he's been
getting his ass beat by Bill that's
that's what I look at when I hear
comments like that ago oh he's a hater
Tom Brady's quarterback that's right I
hear this from coaches all the time yeah
dad and I both you always got Tom Brady
okay great that's great they're 14 and 6
with Adam they would have gone four and
Oh crapola didn't get hurt I mean yeah
they want to go with you Connie but play
a game with one hand and they handed it
off and basically said okay let's just
lose the game we're three and won the
AFC stinks and we'll still get through
this all right so again we're not trying
to sound like Tom Brady haters I just
I'm just trying to let me give you a dog
here's one of my other arguments thank
you guys
right I think Ben Roethlisberger is tier
1 without question okay I don't care if
it's age or what okay man he's he's a
baseball pitcher that has every pitch
yeah right and he has the homerun pitch
and he could strike him out with the
fastball he can throw he is that in the
lead still the best deep thrower in the
NFL yeah he has great touch and you know
when he needs to step on and he can and
he moves around just enough and all
those things and his probably his
biggest downfall man he just there's
this no fear and he's not ready to lose
yes he will throw the pass that will
lose the game and he'll just shrug it
off baby I got no problem with him being
in tier one either I don't have access
that the other involves the other guys I
don't think that's right here's Matt
Stafford level 1 to 10 how much this
upsets you this is from a coordinator he
is so talented but here's my issue they
should have been scoring lots of points
and they never did it falls on him he is
a 1 talent but between a 2 and 3
performer he's got to be more
disciplined but sometimes he freelances
and it takes him a while to get back
then late in the game and it's cover and
the coverage gets generic it's like boom
he gets hot
oh one through ten how much does that
upset you I'm that's a 12 plus I mean
it's like a 10 this idiot yeah what the
hell's he was I listen I watched every
one of these games you know that Adam
and I don't know I just it's hard to
find bad games that he plays and he just
we see the thing about football see I
said I need to say it every year and he
said every week people just go by the
stats and this and that and you have to
see the circumstances which he plays
under and then once you kind of really
just go wow that was an unbelievable
play who could have made that me and I
felt maybe three other guys yeah you go
to a game and all of a sudden you go the
only reason they had a chance to win was
him yeah and all those things you said I
almost disagree with all the defense's
generic he'll pick you apart oh my god
that's that it's frustrating right so
silly all right come on do it
you know what they are they're saying
that well we can't give him any credit
they haven't won a Super Bowl yet and
whatever but my son said it right Namie
there were teams and the guys he's
played with where you go oh man they
should have gone to Super Bowl the
offensive line always seems to have a
problem they can't run the ball and
they've never had any lead pass rusher
and Dominick assuit is a great inside
player but he doesn't sack the
quarterback and disrupt the game like
you know deep like a snowball race right
that would be my other one yeah he's
chronically undervalued it's it's insane
the thing that you realize when you read
quotes like this and I already knew this
but I hope like our listeners in this is
how many clueless people there are there
working in the NFL like we've been
telling you for a long time yeah there's
a there's a handful of them and bias
falls into it like we've always talked
about here's a good one this is my
weight and tier two all these guys you
talked about we got Jimmy Garoppolo and
tier two all right you games right you
know that that's ridiculous I mean it
really is here's carson wentz this is
from a voter
put Wentz in tier 3 okay quote he was
slightly above average as a rookie he
played 12 games in a part of a 13th game
last year with all these guys we should
ask what would they be
with an average supporting cast average
coaching average defense an average
kicking game remember how excited people
were about Derek Carr these young guys
should be slow to ascend what's the rush
well what 1 through 10 I don't know if I
see need to see anymore
I see he's big he's fast he makes
incredible throws he's won games maker
he won games early in the year he did
heven it did have an average supporting
cast an average coaching an average
they're not average anymore that's it's
again it says this this weird thing of
course yeah I mean I don't know what he
single-handedly won games from last year
yes and he was a rookie he did more that
was not a good team they were a little
bit in disarray
you know everybody's wondering conduct
Peters from really be the head coach
yeah all that and now there's a lot of
yes and I did one of his games late in
the year and I watched him and I said
man I know where he is at right now I
was in Seattle they're playing out there
it's cold it's just not a great day and
he didn't throw the ball well he missed
some guys and stuff like that and you
know why he was physically and mentally
exhausted from being the starting
quarterback as a rookie and getting hit
moving around
late in the year that's when it comes I
hate my rookie year we had three games
ago and I remember thinking oh my god I
don't care if we win or lose I just want
to get out of this mmm and because it's
it's brutal it's brutal
it's you see the phrase he was
experienced that he did take a lot of
hits and I know his arm kind of wore out
on him a little his rookie year but with
one year maturing we saw who he truly
was last year the thing that frustrates
me and I hear it in both of your voices
is we can go
these are dumb these GM's and
coordinators must not be paying a 10
this is crazy but for all of the fans
that grew up like myself that relied and
saw oh this is 10 GM's and 5 OCS
I'm gonna take these statistics if I'm a
young person now I'm gonna go this is
must be how the NFL sees it and I'm
gonna trust this and I and I think that
there's a lot of young people or people
that are trying to like a look at the
NFL and they're just being misguided and
these insights these things that I read
about how Eli Manning a GM says I have a
gut feeling that like his brother he'll
play another three years play well and
ride out but what's a Manning was awful
in his last year and I don't understand
what these people are watching and what
they're saying but I really feel like
they're doing young fans into service
and I know it's subjective and people
would say that your rankings are freakin
crazy but I know that you guys are
watching every throw in every play and
know what these guys are capable of it's
something can understand OCS and play
dynamic and stuff like it's hard for the
argue right because a lot of these guys
are do they have an NFL thing there and
they're ba ba they got an NFL card with
a fancy emblem and my names on here and
I know a lot about football I talked
about this with all my coach friends and
people I know in the NFL and I know I've
said it to you before the NFL's is
polluted and as political as ever before
it there's more unaccountable if there's
more unqualified people coaching and
working in front office's than ever
because it's become so popular such big
business that people that are not
qualified of weaseled themselves into
organizations through connections of
people they know instead of what they
know about the actual sport and then
then when they get some of these jobs
they basically do their best to just
never expose themselves and how little
they actually know and that's really one
of the big problems in the NFL and it's
why we see always the same group of
teams basically towards the top of the
NFL because there's only a handful of
smart people that really get the whole
clue of the the NFL and the big picture
and that's why they're always successful
I'll be my little stint there no you are
it's a great speech and you are right
and you know the thing that all these
things that you know I just hate it you
know I just hate it when people
again it's the New England thing but
look what they've built a culture the
players and I'm not just taking a just
this one example but James Harrison all
those walks in there and he just knew
right away who this place is different
and you you know what I went and did
games I always just go there's nobody
like this team nobody practices like
them nobody's as organizes them yeah I
mean nobody right and practice was real
and I could feel the pressure and
attention out there right and I'd be
standing next to Bill Belichick that
you'll hold on a minute
he'd walk away and just get your left
hand on his right shoulder that's all
you're thinking and that is the most
detailed detailed thing that you could
ever do but man they just tore him up
but here that is then he came back and
you know what starts twirling as whistle
and then rip the guy eyes their culture
and and here's the other thing great
coaches Bill Walsh Bill Parcells
they didn't get lucky and the same with
Bill Belichick there's other ones too
but look at their coaching staffs they
know how to pick assistant coaches right
they set the culture you know Adam they
make the environment so great that the
assistant coach can now go has the
attention of his players and he can
coach him and really it's but it takes
the head coach to make them toe the line
and I'm gonna tell this story
Christopher you know Pat Hudson yeah
okay
he was our receiver coach the Giants had
him for many years then he went to the
Jets with Bill Parcells I think he was
tight in coach over there so I'm down
visiting pad down and he's and shoot for
Georgia plays I can't think of the town
office in Georgia Georgia thank you and
I'm visiting there I'm gonna speak in a
lunch in one afternoon so I'm down there
for a few days and we're having dinner
and of course we start talking about the
Giants he starts talking about Bill
Parcells he goes Sims you think you had
it hard how do you think he treated us
coaches and I go Pat I know he was
doodle on the coaches he started just
saying all these things and bad-mouthed
that even this and that and I was just
going man there's some venom coming out
of here it was great it was great I was
laughing I going ding Patton he goes but
you know what if he called me tomorrow I
wouldn't even ask him how much he's
gonna pay me I'll be there
I said where why because he goes I've
never seen him by liking he could get
the team under control and he goes man I
loved the coaching part of it but you
know him yelling at me was okay because
he was at the table so I could coach my
position I just said minutes that's
awesome
and that's that gets lost so football
has so many intricate and things that we
don't talk about that really make a
difference and and we just judge it oh
this guy that guy whatever in ratings
and catches and so when I heard that I
said man that's what it is you know and
and Christopher yeah and Adam yeah think
of who was on our coaching staff I know
charlie weis Tom Coughlin Bill Belichick
Al Groh Romeo Crennel right Ron Earhart
well the best run designing coaches in
the NFL in in history was our offensive
coordinator am i missed anybody no I
mean I think you got all the big ones I
mean hey how is that for a coaching
staff right I mean how you your points
just because it's like you're saying I
mean you go back to Bill Walsh in those
days it's Mike Holmgren it's a it's a
long list of unbelievable guys right
where you go well no wonder they were
good they had big-time coaches at every
position fill we're gonna get to your
top five running backs next week man we
really appreciate you well oh you're
running out of time it's a block yes you
know running so long you know we have to
do is to today's video talk about who's
gonna win a giraffe against a rhino or
something we're taking the brain we're
taking
we actually have the whoa big offseason
Awards the what the whoa big offseason
awards it's wait wait let me get that
knife and stick it in my ear okay that
was fine good talk a little football cuz
I'm starting to get revved up a little
because I steal the season I'm starting
to look at rosters and all that stuff so
it's good whatabout to talk about we go
along here all right dad you the man
pretty happy Oh
last question yeah I got B Anniversary
baby got you on my mind you remember I
saw no oh you idiots what is this well
you would know it that Frankie Valli and
the four seasons and that was the end
I've never heard of them again no I
don't know that one I have to hear it
sorry well you got to look at up happy
Anniversary baby
thanks man all right yeah I hate you
that's good that he knows he only
thought the group text that's are you
gonna did you get it
no and this is why I didn't because
every day is already
she was already she goes well what do
you want to do for our anniversary I may
throw around a few she goes well just so
you know I'm doing this during the day
that was kind of my gift to myself so
there you go yeah exactly that's her
that's her gift he's well rested so I'd
like to say before we get into this
there were some very late entrants to
try and be in the whoa big offseason
Awards but unfortunately the deadline
has already passed number one
JJ Watt and the rock apparently texts
over finding which jeans could fit their
quads great wove story after the
deadline I'm sorry but apparently they
text each other and Joe Thomas saying
that Tyrod Taylor will go to the Hall of
Fame because he's gonna take the bills
to the playoffs of the Browns to the
playoffs that's a super whoa that could
have gone in our wove herb board
category I don't often see Hall of Fame
comparisons oh that's that's very
special but it was after the line so
unfortunately didn't go in there
well yeah Joe Thomas Wow so are you
excited I am it is time
for a 1v only the magical place
we've been here all offseason no whoa
big offseason Awards unbelievable god
it's it's been a long time coming
I had 13 pages of woe stories and now
it's time to go through Josh any remarks
we should have worn tuxedos yeah maybe
next next year we're gonna do this on a
stage next year I like that might not be
anyone there but we'll be on a stage
first category we're gonna get to it's
simply the biggest moment of the
offseason and I guess what man the
biggest moment and there was only one
contestant it's an automatic winner
jibiji going on a date with Chiara Mia
just absolutely incredible congrats to
Jimmy G Jimmy G unreal that was the
woman it was one moment and he
absolutely captured that that's our
biggest woman here's how this is gonna
work for the other leg so many things we
just had a quote come out from his press
conference Jimmy G said on the lessons
he's learned from recent headlines
involving his dating life quote life is
different now I'm under a microscope yes
you are yes you are Vinnie chase when
you get 137 million people watch you
alright so here's how this is gonna work
I have all the different possibilities
for who's gonna win and Chris you have
been bestowed the honor of picking the
ultimate winner oh this is so great it
is alright so in committee our next
category is most confident and here are
the nominees tyree kill who said quote
there's no quarterback who can overthrow
me it's not even possible Dante Jackson
said it's not it's hard not to talk back
to me I keep going I walk it like I talk
it I was born with it
Melvin Ingram said I think it's gonna be
crazy
this Super Bowl were going to win were
ready Malik Jackson says were going 60
nano and Jalen Ramsey said if y'all
thought I was good the past two years
then stay tuned
Tyreke he'll Dante Jackson Melvin Ingram
Malik Jackson
and Ramsey who is the most confident in
this offseason to me it's going Ramsey
or Melvin Ingram and I'm gonna go with
Jalen Ramsey Ramsey whoa yes gon Ramsey
said if y'all thought I was good the
past two years then stay tuned yeah I
mean he's got unbelievable swag about
him anyways and then he's putting like
the other guys didn't quite put personal
pressure on themselves right they found
like Tyree killed kind of by just saying
I can nobody can overthrow me almost a
joke right Melvin Ingram it's a team
thing jaylen Ramsey who was already the
best corner in football is saying you
haven't even seen me yet I'm gonna get
better I give it to him he's the man I
like that all right next one up best
rookie quarterback offseason first one
up Josh Rosen early on he looks unreal
then he had the story where he was
texting Patrick Peterson all the time
right and then there was a story where
Patrick Peterson said he's the real deal
Baker Mayfield is also up for it quote
never have we seen teammates gravitate
to someone like this Sam darn 'old is
also up for this
Sam darn 'old the jet CEO hype darn 'old
as the franchise save our quote I think
when we look back 20 years from now this
is the moment that Jets shifted into a
new year Josh McCown also said with Sam
we have the right guy he's wired the
right way
Josh Allen is also up for it on his high
energy he's high five and in slapping
butts
LeSean McCoy said I've got to be honest
I'm not a fan of rookies but he's
special and Austin prole said that Josh
Allen might have a stronger arm than can
Newton and how could we forget about
Lamar Jackson on one play burst through
the line and another rookie was
hollering on the sidelines his coach
John Harbaugh says he has natural arm
talent Eric Weddle says I've never he's
as talented of a players I've seen in 12
years and CJ Mosley says out of the
pocket he's like a young my
Vick you act like your tank tagging off
because you don't want to be on the
highlight reel of the four rookies Chris
Sims Baker Mayfield Josh Rosen Sam
Darnell Josh Alan Lamar Jackson who has
had the biggest whoa big offseason was a
tough one they've all had a pretty good
office I think Baker Mayfield is the
first guy I cancel out of this because I
don't think anything other than being
drafted number one is that them in whoa
big one so I'm going I'm going
I'm gonna sound like I'm a Homer here
but I'm going with Josh Allen Wow salad
with a surprised victory over Lamar
Jack's I am I'm gonna go with Josh Allen
I think for the reason that I know
there's been a few chinks in the armor
with Lamar Jackson down there hasn't
been perfect like whether it's been they
you know hey there's some great but
there's consistency to the throwing
things like that Josh Sean I've heard
nothing but positive and when you have
guys like LeSean McCoy and true davyous
white coming out and tweeting about him
and saying things the way they were that
just tells me that he's done more than
given like the coaches a little
confidence the the the star players and
their team are going like whoa holy crap
this guy's kind of good good job thanks
thanks Josh out with the surprise well I
really like Sam Donald's offseason too
he was set thought about him very good
officers oh good offseason good all
right now it is time for the best
unknown rookie of the offseason these
are guys not taken in the first round of
course there's Broncos linebacker Josey
Jewell who was raised tending to a
hundred and thirty cattle and 18,000
turkeys and his college coach said he's
ultra ultra competitive
there's dorrance Armstrong who Rod
Marinelli made watch clips of Chris
Dolman to improve there's Josh sweat who
had his locker right near Fletcher Cox
and Brandon Graham and Michael Bennett
and Timmy Jernigan there's Blake jar one
tight end to the Cowboys who has
received tons of praise from Stephen
Jones and then there's wil Hernandez who
has been in five fights and Eli Manning
says I love it
to which will Hernandez
bonden iron sharpens iron Chris Sims of
the five Josey jewel dorrance Armstrong
Josh sweat Blake Jarvan and well
Hernandez who is the whoa
unknown rookie I like Joshua sweat a lot
I have a man crush Jonas is this story
it's not the play that's why I got to go
with will Hernandez bill Hernandez five
fights and Eli Manning loves it loves it
I mean I can promise you the offensive
line coach loves it the offensive line
staff Leslie you don't care about all
the chickens that Josie Jewell raised no
we're seeing someone getting five fights
no and it talks about the culture being
changed they're a little bit like what
Dad was talking about with some of that
it's gonna make the defensive line
better he's getting in fights with Damon
snacks Harrison is like what the hell
I'm the biggest guy around here how dare
you do this to me
and I'm about football is the football
podcast okay players podcast and you
know all the off the field farming
stories are great but I'd stick to the
between the lines all right this one is
a personal favorite for me best
offseason Instagram post Oh
number one or you want me to vote on
this yes okay number one say Quan
Berkeley in the body issue number two
Odell Beckham jr. throws a football 80
yards number three Aaron Donald trains
with knives number four
tio runs a 4 for 40 and number five
Pacman Jones punches a man in the face
and subsequently breaks his ankle so
it's sake one's legs this is a great
category great guy Odell throws at 80
yards Aaron Donald trains with knives
tio runs the 40 where pac-man knocks out
an airport security oh man I did great
list well it's one or five for me right
what's either say Kwan or PAC Finch oh
it's either sake one or pacman all those
stories are good who knew that Aaron
Donald's knife training would not even
make the top two yeah I know the guy was
very kinda stiff he was really trying to
stab them I didn't matter
mess it up with it but I think as much
as I love pac-man knocking out that big
mouth and breaking his ankle because he
got knocked the hell out I got to go
with say quad it's taken over social
media the offseason everything all we've
never for me I'm breaking boundaries
about talking about a man's legs and ass
this much I mean it's we have obsessed
about it either I talked about it right
yeah
that is the first win for say Quan
Barkley the second win for the New York
Giants as a team joining will Hernandez
who won for best unknown rook how did
you touch that ball again why did you do
that you had your fingers in your nose
and now you touch the football again
from earlier yeah well you gotta have
better ball security alright next one up
he's trying to cover his belly in that
sausage sure no honestly it's because I
usually have papers yeah so that I lean
out like this right but now everything's
here and I want to like touch my
computer by the kids I'm trying to
figure it is the best beans not beef
love the offside I am hungry right now
it's first little crap Tariq Cowan
announcing that he's never been to a
Jewish deli
Cameron wake admitting that in his
entire career he's never had fried food
or beer and quote beer will taste the
same in 10 years as it does tomorrow
Bill Belichick staying at a Lowe's
Regency and paying sixty one dollars for
blueberry pancakes or Paul Alexander the
Cowboys offensive line coach saying that
he judges football players based on how
they use ketchup he must either play D
line or o line he can't play for me if
they're smack in the back what kind
what's this category best beans not beef
of the offseason tarik Cohen not going
to a Jewish deli
Cameron week never having a beer during
his career Bella check paying sixty one
dollars for pancakes or the Cowboys
offensive line coach not drafting guys
because they use ketchup wrong yeah I
mean that's a dumb one
room service cost that much Orville
Belgic have you been to in New York City
hotel the first one was : never coming
to a deli I mean are you surprised that
like Jewish delis are not all over the
country it's just written okay so so I'm
going can't wait that's pretty
impressive camera week never having a
beer never eating fried food never
really seems like talked to girls either
I mean totally on the straight and
narrow total professional total nut job
and a right in the right way and that's
kind of what we want with beans and
that's what I mean we want you to never
really enjoy any no fried food I would
have a real issue if I couldn't have
french fries congratulations to Cameron
Wake it's his first nomination and the
first win and the beans not beef
category he looks like a Greek god are
you taking notes of what we've awarded
so what have we awarded so far say Quan
Berkeley okay biggest woman went to
Jimmy G yes
most guys most confident went to jail
and Ramsey he's not even listening to
you
biggest rookie quarterback offseason
went to Josh Allen best unknown rookie
went to wil Hernandez best offseason IG
post went to say Quan Barkley best beans
not beef went to Cameron Wake and now
that's right veteran free agent teddy
bridgewater created a quote legitimate
buzz during OTAs Baker Mayfield on Josh
Gordon I have never seen anybody like
him Vernon Davis on lavishes veteran
Vernon Davis on Alex Smith he has so
many scars he's successful not by
accident it's supposed to be it's
inevitable look at his scars
Tyrod Taylor had multiple nominations
Todd Haley his car is there every
morning in his spot when I get there and
it's like he's not leaving Jarvis Landry
called him the starting quarterback
Christian Kirksey said we've never had
this module on the offensive side of the
ball and Case Keenum
who was called a bonafide leader he's
our guy for the season what's the first
one first one was Teddy Bridgewater
illegitimate buzz
Josh Gordon I've never seen anyone like
him Alex Smith has scars
Tyrod Taylor his cars in the parking lot
and Case Keenum is a bona fide leader
the wou big offseason award for veteran
edition I think go with the Tyrod Taylor
I think it's it's more than just your
normal Oh Sam Bradford's goodies are
starter all we're gonna trade away cart
trade him away start carson ones like
they went above and beyond them just
like normal propaganda that i go let's
try to make our guy feel like he's the
starter know when players and defensive
players and everything like that start
to talk about it and then the offensive
coordinator opens up about your work
ethic which i don't think he would do
unless he was really really ultra
impressed and he was really impressing
people especially when there's the first
pick of the draft there at your position
i would say he wins that a word wow yeah
gratulations graduate IRA taylor speeds
was definitely the best free agent
edition in terms of like buzz then
everyone's talking about yeah mother
nominee he's like jimmy graham was up
there and rogers like oh he catches
everything with his hands right Tyrod
Taylor I think was the runaway winner
yeah it gives an organization that has
not had stability it gives them a guy at
quarterback who's very professional
gonna keep his you know nose and head
down go to work and he's won football
games been in the playoffs and was in a
really good organization before that
with the Baltimore Ravens so knows what
it takes I appreciate how seriously
you're taking I am yes alright next any
more categories right yep three mom he's
counting down just say of course this is
best quote of the offseason Oh
Gerald McCoy talking about Vito veía
when he introduces himself to my kids
you will introduce yourself as Maui
after no questions asked cuz he says he
looks like the character from Moana
right Donald Penn talking about Jon
Gruden after the draft I'm not gonna lie
I saw the draft but that called Gruden I
was like man what the [ __ ] he didn't
answer but when I saw him the next
Monday he was joking you really kicked
my ass huh Donald you were mad as a
[ __ ]
little Musgrave talking about gee that
going down yeah bill Musgrave talking
about Jake but
he's gonna be a terrific asset for us it
was a good one
Dave pepper on Ron Rivera Ron is a
natural defensive guy like walking down
the street and drinkin water just
natural and the last one Joe wit the
Packers defensive passing game
coordinator you cannot tell the
difference between a confused player and
a coward
they both move slow so it's that guy Ron
Rivera drinking water Jake but is an
asset Donald Penn's Gruden imitation and
Gerald McCoy saying Vito veía has to be
the guy from mallanna I really like them
a coy one but it doesn't beat Donald
Penn and Gruden that's amazing
I mean I first of all I am course I'm
biased they know both of them but I just
can totally envision that conversation
and I can also envision Gruden looking
at his phone like seeing Donald Penn's
call and after he's drafted the kid from
Louise Miller
yeah called Miller and literally like
grinning like he's pissed off pissed off
Donald that's I just can see it happened
the best quote of the offseason Donald
Penn imitating John is awesome all right
two more this is a new category just
started it's called most overboard and
it is presented is in honor of nay Brown
over mu nay Brown was the Eagles player
that's the reason that we started whoa
big offseason which is a guy that gets
overhyped but we know that it's probably
not that's why we started this because
of this guy okay my gosh it was because
of Nate Brown so so really what it is is
these are the whoa big off seasons that
we know we're probably [ __ ] yes okay
guy right
first one foremost move excited of this
one that's a good category for most will
report Mike McCarthy says DeSean Kaiser
would have been a first-round pick in
this year's travel without Sevilla
that's beyond vulvar microtesla holy
crap the Saints coaches have never seen
anybody like Saints backup backup
quarterback Taysom Hill he might be the
strong
sky on the team pound-for-pound he's a
freak athlete I've never seen anyone
like pretty over ball pretty well
Nate sub felt like Smith getting wide
receiver Mac Holland says that he could
potentially be an MVP Nate Sud felt the
third string quarterback on the Eagles
he's saying that about Matt Collins no
no Matt Collins said that about Nate Sud
felt that he could be the next MVP what
Andrew Norwell on Blake bortles he's one
of the best I've ever been around and
and the collective of Davis Webb stories
I mean Andrew Doral has only been around
one of the guy Cam Newton you know all
right so the five most to o-over boards
are McCarthy saying DeSean Kaiser would
have been a first-round pick in this
year's draft the Saints coach is saying
they've never seen anyone like Taysom
Hill Mack Hollins saying Nate Sud Feld
could potentially be an MVP in the NFL
Andrew Norwell saying Blake bortles is
one of the best I've ever been around
and the collection of Davis Webb stories
which is most wove aboard
oh gosh somebody's got to go do
psychological evaluations on Matt
Collins he's he's taking hallucinogenic
drugs is that gonna be the most yes what
oh you mean the guy that was a low round
draft pick and got cut by the last TV
was on and now he's a third stringer for
your team yeah he's gonna win the MVP
I'm sure they're gonna ngratulations to
their sport night buddies and all that
but man you'd make me not want to listen
to anything you say when you say dumb
[ __ ] like that yeah I liked all those
stories they were those are those are
the most over board stories in honor of
named Brown yes all right and that
brings us down to the last one
uh-oh what is the last one what are you
doing over there Oracle we got it I'm
just looking up some neighbor and stuff
okay what do you think I'm doing the
last one at a Google Doc the last one is
the whoa big offseason MVP award you'd
think it might be but there's a lot of
people up for this we got five
contestants okay number one
Tyrod Taylor we've already gone into the
winner he was the winner of the new
veteran free agent Tyrod Taylor
his parking spot the juju he should be
starting quarterback the juju the Jew
that he's brought to the team Oh
his vibe his essence the second person
up for MVP say Quan Barclay legs and ass
he was also complimented by a lot of
former Giants quarterbacks and all the
stories that have come out for him
number three Patrick mahomes turned down
all of the endorsements and Andy Reed
compared him to Brett Favre the run
number four Odell Beckham jr. not only
did he start and helped propel the
shitty dance
he also posted a lot of training videos
and followed left go PR he also won the
most fashionable athlete in the world
and he was accused of doing drugs whoa
big offseason with the shaky dances the
what dashiki to him my feelings that
when he like you shake your foot and hop
around I don't know that's different way
no that's not shoe
I know the tickle I know the floss jiggy
dance it was a Drake things hole friend
and then the number five Davis Webb said
that his arm is almost too strong got a
printer in the facility his nickname is
the dragon he's back to his roots
wearing boots
he creates playlists for him and Eli
Manning he never stops working even
during his vacation and he's just the
dragon so that should be like whoa over
board that was like wool verb or too
much he was up for Ava's red propaganda
SH so the five contestants for the whoa
offseason MVP Tyrod Taylor Patrick
mahomes Davis Webb say Quan Berkeley and
Odell Beckham jr. Sims it's the hardest
category it is it's a good category cuz
those are some good ones who is gonna be
is between mahomes obj and say quad in
my opinion
wow you're eliminating Davis Webb
without a
dragon yeah no sorry I mean this entire
offseason has been about David sweat
he's owned the Aussies yeah he talks
about himself too much and he ain't done
anything yet can't do it captain sorry
negative ghostrider
yes unbelievable shut your [ __ ] mouth
people are really shocked right now
Thank You Jonah I mean people can't I'm
shocked so that means that it's down to
a surprise three yeah sake one Barkley
Odell Beckham and who Patrick homes Wow
when you say you turned down yet again
Patrick mahomes beats out Davis Webb for
a spot just like it's back at Texas Tech
so it's say Quan O'Dell and Patrick
mahomes do you want to just yeah let's I
think I have to go to say Quan Barkley
yes
I mean sake what Barkley had an off
season them I mean come on
unprecedented offs unprecedented we went
from everybody evaluating the draft and
thus all watching him for like three
minutes and going holy [ __ ] he's
unbelievable he's definitely one of the
best players in the draft and the
discussion goes to the combine we go
holy crap he's more of a physical freak
than we thought he was high then it goes
from there to go okay is there anything
wrong with him there are any chinks in
the armor does he have the issues oh no
he's the most stand-up guy that came out
in the draft he's got a million-dollar
smile
ESPN Body Issue sake quads in the locker
room I mean it's daily updates about him
working out and his body so that's why I
got to give it to him Wow what do you
think Josh I had Davis Webb pegged for
that category I'm considering this a
huge upset and I'm gonna have to
question the voting committee on this
it's pretty incredible Davis Webb after
the the supposed MVP of the whoa big
offseason walks away with no trophy I
know
I'd like to crying sound in there no
crying huh and I got to point out here
three awards for Giants gets two and I'm
one for will Hernandez you would not
expect the Giants to really be a
lobokoff season organization they had a
great
they really did so I'd like to once
again honor rookie quarterback offseason
goes to Josh Allen best offseason
Instagram goes to say Quan Barkley most
confident goes to jail and Ramsey
unknown rookie goes to Will Hernandez
new free agent vet
Tyrod Taylor held that down beans not
beef Cameron wake of the Miami Dolphins
best quote goes to Donald Penn and Jon
Gruden their collaboration most whoa
verb ORD that's gonna go to Nate's on
felt and Mac Hollins for calling him a
future MVP and the biggest whoa meant
Jimmy G and Chiara Mia late submission
late submission but got in there just in
time and the whoa big offseason MVP say
Quan say quads Barkley yes
disappointing that Odell didn't get any
love I wanted to know what's up for two
categories but he was beaten by say quad
and both right I know he's also beaten
and by and guaranteed money all right
that's how did that feel good that was
the collection of the offseason what do
you think venture I think we could put
some tuxedos on next year and do that do
that big-time absolutely not
I think so too we're gonna attack see
now we're gonna have to get say Quan on
here to accept his award but that was
awesome it's it's fitting that we do
that now training camps are starting
there's gonna be a lot of woes stories
coming out so we'll continue whoa big
offseason but that's it's after the
calendar you know big training camp well
thank you yeah you're the man whoa big
training camp the first preseason game
of the year is next Thursday it is the
hall of fame game and that is why now we
are gonna be joined by David Baker
president of the Hall of Fame to kind of
talk about that again we get into tea Oh
what's going on with that we talk about
do guys get too fat for their jackets
does anyone not like their bus by the
way we think the answer to the question
that he would answer is Tony Dungy
you'll kind of see you hear it a little
bit later but enjoy David I know that
that would we think we think we don't
know and then we looked up we looked up
Tony Dungy is bust and look it doesn't
look good
so guys enjoy this interview we will be
back on Monday we love you so much for
Sims
peace out homies for
pendrick good evening you did this at
the enemy did so double farewell here's
David Baker what's up man how you doing
today doing good guys you're ready for
the to kick-off the 99th season of the
NFL you know it is that what it is 9999
next year of course is the hundredth
season of the NFL that means this year
everyone's just gonna be thinking about
next year
99 yeah all right so we're welcoming in
the the main man the president of the
Pro Football Hall of Fame David Baker a
man that I see every year at the Super
Bowl 16w party and every year I go he is
6 9 400 pounds he is the man what is up
David well I'm probably a little bit
more than 400 pounds right now Chris but
I'd say it's great to be with you and
Adam and we're excited about kicking off
the NFL's 99th season well I appreciate
the honesty there on the weight so I
mean why you're being honest though so
tell us the real number because it is a
very good 400 pounds I will value the
parry or a dense naturally huge person
so yes what is it give us give us a
round about I would say today it's about
two dozen Twinkies above 400 pounds I
love Twinkies today I looked up here I
didn't realize I had always assumed you
played football I didn't realize you put
you're a professional basketball player
in Switzerland yeah that was about 150
pounds ago wow did you just body people
up on the block well I was I probably
should have been a football player but
frankly when I was a kid neither my
parents could read or write and they
weren't they were they're good
hard-working loving people but they
weren't that sophisticated and I you
know in those days they Wade you to play
youth tackle football and so I kind of
weighed too much I played a flag
football and loved that but by time I
got to high school I went to a high
school where you could only play one
sport in the fall and one sport in this
range and I ended up playing basketball
but it was good enough to get me to
college to law school and kind of around
the world that's amazing David I always
ask people this it's part of our podcast
really because people just sometimes
can't understand how big's like the
house big someone like you can actually
so this might sound weird but I'd like
to know how big were your parents like
I'd like you know we've actually read
that the parents leave because everyone
likes to use the cop-out now of like oh
he's big he must be on pretty you know
performance-enhancing drugs he's got to
be doing something like that and I go
well you got to see some of these guys
parents and you'll understand so let me
hear your parents well my dad was
probably about six three to fifty my mom
was about 511 so they were good size but
I'm actually on performance-enhancing
Donuts question about weight I've always
wondered you measure these guys for the
gold jackets has anyone ever like gained
a lot of weight and the jacket didn't
fit like what do you guys do if they
outgrow these jackets you know what yeah
I'll tell you we've got a wonderful
partner in Haggar that is in charge of
the gold jacket so they make sure that
they fit absolutely properly when we
have the gold jacket but it's a it is a
wonderful wonderful you know we've got
77 events over about 10 days with 4,800
volunteers six national broadcast and
it's like I said it's a it's a wonderful
kickoff to the NFL's 99 season with the
Bears and the Ravens and it's what we've
all been waiting for so it's a lot of
events they take time Brett Favre owns
the record for longest speech 36 minutes
do you think Ray Lewis is going to go
longer because that's my that's my
favorite for longest speech this year
you know I actually think Brett's was
longer and I think Jerry Jones might
have been longer than Bret's but we're
doing our best to try to get guys to you
know keep it to 15 minutes you know
because we do have a lot of Hall of
Famers sitting there as well and what we
found in past years quite honestly guys
is that that guy whose last Ray Lewis
will be last yeah and if the other guys
go long Ray Lewis is going to be on at
midnight and that's not merely him last
year Kurt Warner got on row late but it
is a special moment for these guys
because you know they're not speech
makers they're not politicians they're
not preachers but it is the journey of
their life
it is how they got to this very special
place that is on earth going to honor
their legacy forever and you know
there's people who help them get there
their stories and through the
understanding of their stories of the
values that they relied upon the rest of
us can get some inspiration and some
knowledge as well why we're peeling back
the curtain here - and I'm gonna steal
left coast question cuz I thought it was
a good one when he we were talking about
this little before we talk about the
jackets but how about the bus just the
actual bronze figures you know has
anybody ever been unhappy did you ever
have to redo it and go okay yeah this
doesn't quite look the way you wanted to
we'll go back to the drawing board you
know since I've been here we have one
and I'm not going to say who that is but
I can tell you that they're done by a
national artist Blair buswell who is you
know incredibly well renowned as a
sculptor and they begin that literally
the day after the Super Bowl Wow you
know we have selection Saturday we
reveal everybody to the nation on the
honor show then we kind of take them to
the Super Bowl they're introduced during
the first quarter break but the next day
we start our orientation and they get
measured that day because it literally
takes about eight months to get this
bronze sculptor done that is I'm told
it's going to last for 40,000 years and
then you take you have to have that
bronze sculpture because the ring of
excellence that we give them in their
stadium in front of their fans in the
fall actually has a replica of their
bronze bust on the side of the Ring of
Excellence right that ring I'm told
takes 11 weeks to make Wow
I mean I know it's not an easy job I
certainly do do respect it wait so just
you're not gonna tell us who it is can
you tell us the year offense defense or
moaner yeah can you tell us one of those
I can tell you that you guessed none of
those which probably leaves one category
so it's it's got to be a like a
contributor something like that or yes
right yes or maybe a coach oh yeah I
didn't say coach so
like it's alright so as we're peeling
back the curtain we're not gonna give
the coach's name up but how does this
conversation to go does he call you and
like hey David Baker you know thanks for
putting me in the Hall of Fame the
jacket fits great but damn I don't look
like that can we change that how does
that go it was that it was actually his
wife but our job is really you know our
job is to honor these guys yes you know
our mission here at the Hall of Fame
which we take extremely seriously is to
honor the heroes of the game to preserve
its history promote its values and
celebrate excellence everywhere and
while there have been 300 million young
men that have played this game five
million in college 29,000 to a plated
professionally you know there's only 300
and kin right now as of today who have a
bronze bust now Chris you know because
you played in the league we have an
archive here on you every guy who ever
played in the league even for a week if
you won't need a David don't worry you
can put that one in the trash I am NOT
going to be there so don't worry well on
the contrary you can come here and you
can add to that archive you know and you
can kind of you know leave your
grandchildren's grandchildren's
grandchildren's grandchildren or message
as to not only what you are and what you
did but who you are so so our job is to
keep the legacy for all the guys who
played begin do so more appreciated you
Sims famously his spleen exploded and I
was curious if we tracked it down and
got it bronzed would the Hall of Fame be
interested in his spleen that he lost on
an NFL field yeah not only would we
accept that as a donation we could give
him a tax write-off for it as well
that's what I was looking for there's
the payback finally for losing that damn
organ so I'm realizing Dave you're kind
of in an interesting situation you are
the guy you knock on the door you
congratulate people you welcome to the
Hall of Fame you're what's perfect about
the Hall of Fame
sometimes Sims and I get upset about the
voters and their process and the bias
and I want to be honest with you the
teal thing has kind of
it's made me feel a certain type of way
and I just want to be honest with you
because I really respect you a lot
and it's not like David's the one
everybody's a guy that goes there and
goes congratulations you're the man and
David such an awesome guy but I don't
know it's it's kind of making me feel a
type away and I just I wanted you to
kind of comfort me yeah left goes a
little angry about the backlash of
people that are mad at tio we understand
Tio's argument to a degree and we know
you've had a deal with a lot of Dorf t
oh crap here the last few weeks and
months so well you know what's what's
that whole process been like for you
well let me first go back to the first
question you asked if it's okay you know
about the process you know I don't get a
vote we have 48 elite selectors who
literally work year-round they take this
fiduciary obligation I assure you
extremely seriously Peter King tells me
that he does about a hundred and twenty
interviews a year that have nothing to
do with the stories they just have to do
what should a guide be in the Hall of
Fame and you know so they take it very
seriously now I don't have a vote but
you kind of got to be six nine and four
hundred pounds to run this meeting ten
or twelve hours to get through this
process on Selection Saturday and I got
to make sure that they're done so that
we get them out in time to be on the
honor show national television be
revealed to the nation but what I would
say this is that you've got to get
eighty percent of those forty eight guys
in that room and go through a long
process through the year to get into the
room eighty percent for 48 guys it is an
incredibly high bar and respectfully I
would say that it should be hard to get
into Hall of Fame it's not the hall of
very very good it's the hall of fame for
goodness sakes and it is challenging and
there are incredible credible legacies
you know lynn swann I think took 14
times Chris Carter was in on three times
and then said once he was in the room at
the Ray Nitschke luncheon with all the
Hall of Famers he thought you know shame
on me for being concerned that I didn't
make it in here right away it's not
and in many respects you know the guys
who are in the hall are defined by the
guys who aren't in the hall you know
Chris respectfully your dad is a guy who
contributed an enormous amount of the
game and he's not in the Hall of Fame
his legacy is still here we will guard
that here forever maybe someday he'll be
in the Hall of Fame but it's not easy
yet in the Hall of Fame and respectfully
it shouldn't so let me go to your second
question about tio yeah you know him
that come is kind of unprecedented we've
never had that before
and anyone ever threatened like at all
even like I have a talk about you know I
know you're not gonna say their name but
just as it didn't even come close to
this before have you ever had anything
like this no no I mean that's an easy
question to answer no yeah right
everybody has been excited to come want
to come honored to come and again we're
disappointed that tio isn't coming
because really we want to honor him and
we will honor him not just at this
ceremony but you know for the rest of
time with his bus being here and his
legacy here we're going to keep that
alive he is welcome to come to this day
to the enjoyment and after the enjoyment
if he doesn't come he's welcome to come
every day for the rest of his life but
he's also a grown man and we've had some
good discussions that I would say our
respectful discussions and he gets to
make his own mind I can't force him to
come I shouldn't force him to come he
made his mind up so we respect that now
having said that we got seven other guys
who have incredible legacies who have
done tons for the game as well and we're
gonna spend a lot of time focusing on
those guys and have an incredible party
we actually have more Hall of Famers
coming to the Hall of Fame this year
than ever before we should have about a
hundred and forty Hall of Famers Wow
which when you consider that we've only
got counting the new in Chinese 182 who
are alive wow that's that's a pretty
good response for this kind of it's kind
of the tio effect I feel like all of a
sudden everyone's looking at their own
their own jackets and their own rings
and being like man this really I want to
be there maybe it's
had that effect well listen I know you
guys I know you guys are funny I listen
to your podcast but I also want to tell
you I know how much you guys love the
game yes and it's on sale when you get
into a room with a hundred and forty of
these guys I've had the trip to go to
Israel with 20 of them - we've had ten
in front of the Pope and I'm through my
life and career I've had the opportunity
to be with a lot of famous people and
I'm kind of become not a very great
respecter of Fame because I've learned
that most of them aren't that happy but
I'll tell you you get 140 of these guys
in a room it's a pretty impressive group
yeah I remember when I remember when
Michael Strahan was an inch ready he
literally ran taking selfies from
hall-of-famer to hall-of-famer and it
wasn't guys like Joe Montana or Dan
Marino
it was Charlie trippy and it was Hugh
McColl Haney and it was Bob Sinclar and
some of the guys who had started this
game and I think Michaels got a good
understanding for the history of this
game so it's a it's a pretty impressive
group to have these guys together and
again they're not perfect they didn't
fall out of bed great everyone single
one of them overcame a some adversity in
their life so it might have been
physical it might have been but you know
business it might have been emotional
but they've overcome adversity and it's
not just about the worship of the
football hero it's about the focus on
the values that these guys used and
Chris very seriously that you employed
you know even as a college athlete to
the discipline the perseverance they you
know the commitment the love that you
felt for teammates in your team and they
use those values over a long period of
time to drag a whole lot of other people
to a place of excellence with them and
if we look at that and learn at that
well then maybe we can become you know
better broadcasters or a better
administrator or police officer soldier
cellist in the symphony right and we can
become a better community or even a
better country yeah I hear you there
there's so much to respect about these
guys and they did not get there
just by luck or a flip of the coin
they've done a lot to sacrifice to get
there and I do respect that you know
even saying that so this is why I'm glad
you kind of went there you know I know
this is not a perfect process do you
guys behind the scenes evaluate your
approach sometimes and I'm saying this
just because like for me as a true
football lover and a historian and you
know growing up in it I do look at the
Hall of Fame as times and go oh lineman
get cheated a little bit in this process
because it's not sexy they're not on you
know the highlight shows all the time
you know is there ever talks behind the
scenes with the voters or anything like
that like hey we need to do more due
diligence on guys like you know Joe
Jacobi or Alan Faneca where some sports
writers might not actually know how
great he they were because they didn't
watch film or don't know oh line play I
just was wondering how many of those
kind of conversations come up all the
time I gotta tell you that we've got
three different groups here at the Pro
Football Hall of Fame we've got the
selectors we're the guys who you know
cast the ballots and again 80% of those
48 guys have to get them there's also a
contributors committee yeah there's also
a seniors committee that senior
committee is to try to take into effect
guys like Joe Jacobi who may have fallen
between the cracks right and then all of
a sudden you know that they'd look at
them over and over again and it's a
smaller group that looks like a small
group of guys over a whole day that's
how Robert Brazil made it in that's how
Jerry Kramer made it gotcha now this
year they may have fallen between the
cracks and the seniors group is to go
back and relook at that the second group
is really our board of directors and our
board of directors is a group of people
who again are selfless and dedicated and
take this you know to this is not cheap
what we do here I mean you know there's
a whole you know perspective of what
we're doing and we're building a place
called Johnson Controls Hall of Fame
Village around the hall that's about 889
million dollars that's going to be a
Disneyland for football but that Board
of Directors also looks
every year at how can we do this better
how do we set the rules you know we have
bylaws that we have to live by and the
board sets those rules and then finally
we have my staff the group who works for
me and our group is to take the
selections that are made
make sure the bylaws are adhered to and
to honor these guys to fulfill our Mason
mission to honor the heroes of the game
to preserve its history we got 6 million
pictures and 40 million documents here
so the history of the game really is
here to preserve to promote its values
and to celebrate excellence everywhere
that's our mission so those are the
three groups it's kind of like you know
the the legislature the presidency and
the judiciary
you know that they all work together and
it's not just a situation where guys
mail this in or send in their email vote
I assure you that this is something that
is taken incredibly seriously and on
multiple levels people spend a whole lot
of time working it it's still not a
perfect system yeah I don't know that
any system is perfect but I'll tell you
people spend a lot of time on it and
that's why again you know our job is to
honor the guys who are the Hall of
Famers but it's also to honor the guys
you know Chris since I've got you here
you know what your dad right what
yourself and these guys are heroes of
the game as well that's cool I'm glad
you gave us a little peek behind I and I
know that really everybody works
extremely hard on this I just want I
want to hear kind of the behind the
scenes process all right we have to let
you go but one last thing I mean David
your middle name what's your what's the
C for isn't it C dot David Baker I mean
I noticed that when I Wikipedia did you
later earlier today yeah I used to tell
girls it was Cowboys but but in reality
it's actually Carl I was named after my
dad okay and and so it's Carl David
Baker okay cool I just wanted to make
sure you weren't scared of the name
Christopher Chris like me we could have
been besties we could have been best
friends they just wanted to make sure
you know what I hope we're gonna be best
friends anyways we are we already
dude we appreciate your time you're a
good protector of the realm
I feel like the Hall of Fame is is this
beautiful world and you protect it we
are going to bother the contributor
committee I think with our fan base next
year to try and get phil simms in so I'm
gonna have my people talk to your people
about who we should be bothering but I
just absolutely yeah because I let me
let me share with you any fan can
nominate just by writing me here at the
Pro Football Hall of Fame any fan can
nominate someone we get it down to a
hundred then we get it to then we get it
to 50 then we get it to 25 then we get
it to those 18 that go in the room how
we'd love to have that nomination
how many fan nominations would our fans
need to send in for you to go guys we
got like 500 phil simms nominations like
what's the number to where you're like
this was overwhelming like our fan base
needs to know that number one all you
need is one women on the list we send it
to our our contributors and what they
need to do is you know talk to the
contributors and do that but the
contributors then vote all the
nominations that we get and they get
them down to a hundred than 250 then to
25 and 18 okay we're gonna get your
information we're gonna start a movement
for phil simms but Dave we appreciate
your time enjoy the weekend check it out
Canton they're going we have an events
all throughout the week it's gonna be on
everything ESPN NFL Network all that
good stuff
and Brian Dawkins the greatest safety to
ever play the game is gonna have an
amazing stage the Eagles fan David it's
a you can't help it
well listen here every one of these guys
is gonna have a incredible speech and I
know Brian will as well he's a fine
young man but I've been impressed with
Randy Moss and Carey Kramer who waited
45 years to get in here you don't think
he's going to have something to say
right we're excited about it's gonna be
great guys finally here that's here
thanks David that's a grown man we
appreciate it thanks guys sitting here
got back the big man the big Baker he is
are we still rolling
yeah okay he's we say this every time
you
we have to though he's a largest human
being I've ever seen I mean he would you
could stand him next to Jonathan Ogden
and go which one was the Hall of Fame of
tackle he's the closest real person I've
ever seen - Andre the Giant like when I
hear stories about Andre the Giant just
the size of his hands I go up and shake
his hand one out of respect right but -
because I just want to I've never felt
my hand feel that small yeah no it's
amazing he's a giant he really is all
right so what do you think about
everything he said I can't get mad at
David for anything no no of course
David's just what he said there's no
system that's ever right right we just
get upset at the system node and there
was I think the one the one other thing
I wanted to ask him but I you know I
don't know if it's worth asking because
he's gonna answer it the right way is
always about do people the voters I
would like to know do they really do
they ever complain about I mean like
will you complain like Jerry Jones
getting in the Hall of Fame like the
billion dollar owner all he contributed
to help his huge investment that says
whole life and family's life is
dependent on yeah well what a
contributor I wonder if there's any of
that backlash because I'd love to I
wanted to ask him and obviously I
wouldn't not in this space and he's
gonna give us the right answer but being
like look man you got Kurt Warner and
Terrell Davis who like had these shorter
like explosive careers and they're on TV
all the time like I wonder with the
coaches I think that's good to know
all right so the coach that has a bad
bust I think if we just search like new
busts for coach maybe it'll pop up yeah
I'll do it okay but check it out I the
Hall of Fame is gonna be coming up so
you guys can roll we're gonna sell gonna
in the podcast so you can play the music
now thank you guys so much I hope you
enjoyed the whoa big offseason Awards
Wow I hope that you guys enjoyed our
little talk with Phil Simms we will be
back on Monday as always it will be
great and on Monday
we're on the same week as the first
preseason game Booya holy crap the Hall
of Fame Game Bears Ravens will be on
Thursday night bears what is your
prediction do you think Ray Lewis goes
over 36 minutes he is the caboose he's
last they go to last for a reason you're
right that's right n even realized he
was last it's gonna be right around I
don't think he's gonna go over it I
don't I think he'll be conscious of the
fact that it was like he was like we
don't have any
preachers like Luis is going to be a
preacher yes Ray Lewis is good up me up
there and be like I have reached the
summit of my career
I'm gonna go momentum is real yeah it'll
be good all right for Simms
peace out homies for Fenric good evening
and for the lef koe man we appreciate
you guys to the LSL FL faithful meatloaf
and all the fans out there making us
enjoy our jobs we love you and we'll
holler at you next week